I got to leave if you wanna do some with
him now mr. Witherspoon bunnies man in
the world yeah
come see the movie cuz yeah there's a
lot of surprises don't be home peace ha
get a job get a job kids of America
please get a damn job
let's take your father yo yes get out at
the house either refrigerator Oh search
alone get a job spend your own money
because you got hold on it
I have a kid that six years old I want
him to get a job I'm from a kind of 11
kids my family we're letting kids not
family that's my father's team get up in
the morning hello dance get a job got my
shoe who took my car were mikake get a
job America you young kids get a job
sagging them poles hanging on man that
don't mean nothin get a job you want to
be somebody get a job
hi John how are you are you taking oh
well that's great
we uh you need somebody that Facebook
thanks well how you guys are doing how
can attain without doing just a fine
show
thank you and we're happy to be on holy
all the time that we do all the time
look at that family fitness you
yes term is a John Wayne okay yes this
is a family a family that works together
and the women spend a lot of time
dealing with their hair and Eugene and
their nail Craig plays ice cube in the
movie
oh my smiley yes
these are pitches where they take
pictures of you in and they frames me
put them on the set but we put together
for long no 1803 mrs. Jose as parents I
think of a good mommy and daddy would
you want to spoil your mother's father's
right
[Applause]
there's a family with a sense of humor
that's right and I think that's why the
being as perfect as I am stayed with
this man for so many years
right dying perfect a man who is
imperfect but I'm not perfect I've only
been here for like an hour but every
time that they have a line that comes
from you and the director Gary's
throwing the line it's already sunk
right yeah it's playing bobbing is it
probably yeah well I'm a father who
wants his son to do better than the sit
around the house i watch TV and he beat
up on food yeah my son a guy to get a
job ha ha two American kids yeah yes
yeah I'm eating up all the food cuz I'll
get some work all costs money
that's right but it no it really is
interesting because what it is it's it
tells the story of what happens inside
the house compared to what happens
outside there's still the dangers there
but you realize that we have set
perimeters and values and we have
aspirations for our children now
hopefully they will live up to that and
hopefully nobody gets shot and I think
you see some of the some of the drama
the reality of the outside world coming
in to this family this kind of
self-contained families the comedy stuff
commander
oh that's Bonnie it's Bonnie well this
man the funniest part is that he is a
dog catcher
yes a dog and I love dogs so I have
about what my collection of ceramic dogs
that includes one stuff one is about a
hundred and fifty nine yes and the dog
catcher he's a dog catcher we have a
topic there ain't no conflict you just
don't touch my dog yes ma'am yeah that's
all
well you do some riot you know guys that
play cops you know do the ride-alongs on
the cop said he didn't done some
ride-alongs and SPCA you know the kiss
dogs I mean the dog bit me a long time
ago when I was pursuing my career as a
boxer a dog bit me and put me out of
business
so I am pursuing all dogs keep your dogs
inside it's a nice community because we
live on one block and we've been there
like 20 years so we know that the kids
even the ones who are trying to be a bad
influence on my children thank God my
kids turned out perfect but anyway
there's a reference at the end of the
piece where you know one of the
neighbors saw him get knocked down
check out his nails knows a lot of time
has to be spent adhere dresses and at
the nail shops this is very important
I'd pay for all this in order to keep a
man you have to have nice nails honey
that's right baby and good I'm every
father I'm not only black father I'm a
white father right I'm a Chinese father
Mexican father Oh father
they want their sons out of the house
and get a job please you kids turn the
music down
of all the children in the country
sixteen foot doggy dog what was it when
you were I wouldn't sing at all while he
was around so many grapes this is the
fifteenth take I used to love grapes
loved them until tonight it was a whole
bag when you started yeah look at there
[Music]